hi everyone it's Jerry I have a chess
miniature to share with you from the
1982 Olympiad a 21 mover between Gary
Kasparov on the white end
and John Nunn
the opening is a benoni defense
and so inherent with the benoni are some
quick imbalances with the structure each
side now has a majority of Pawns
black with the three to two on the queen
side
white with the two to one in the center
each side respects these majorities
takes at least one step in an offensive
or defensive way in this game to address
their advance
we continue with G6
and now move 7 F4 this
signals the pawn storm variation
white is now looking to push with E5
he's looking to set into motion his
majority
Bishop G7
and in the game it's Bishop B5 check
if white plays E5 here it is too soon
overextended Pawn really with there now
being three attackers and only one
Defender it would be very difficult for
white to maintain E5 if not impossible
to maintain E5
so more development on this move 8 and
its Bishop B5 check
now with this Pawn storm variation when
Bishop B5 check lands
it pretty much forces an only reply
black must underdevelop the Knight black
must take into account the E5 push
this underdeveloping move has opened up
the Bishop's eyes to this advance
E5 would also no longer be hitting with
tempo
why is it important for black to
underdevelop
with Knight F to D7 in the pawn storm
variation let's have a look at the other
ways to block
with the queen side miners
I want to at least give you a feel for
each of these moves
E5 hits in both cases
so let's put some moves on and I'm going
to ask a question to Black how do you
feel in this position
how do you feel having to work around
two White ponds this Pond Duo Central
duo in your house these nights I can
tell you are not thrilled the white
Knights are
they're on their favorite Square just
look at the Knight quality here in the
central ponds
one other quick note there's a reason
why I'm taking with the queen in this
position she watches over G4 if you take
with the Knight G4 could hit and this
guy is cooked
okay
one other one
if you're blocking with this yet again
E5
and the E Pawn is not done E6 White's
taking advantage of this pin but be
aware that's not the end of the story
here it can get messy
after Queen H4 check we got some wild
continuation like this where eventually
white is going to have the two minor
pieces versus The Rook
okay
we have some idea now what's maybe
happening if these guys Block in the
game best move Knight fd7 and let me
throw this position to you as a pop quiz
what would you play here
feel free to pause the video
okay in the game it is A4 a move that
takes into account
the majority
this is a defensive move it's not
allowing black to expand on the queen
side so easily
If instead of A4
we have this Supernatural looking knight
F3
in comes A6 now what do you do you want
to give up Bishop per night help black
develop or are you going to retreat in
comes B5 and now all of a sudden as
white you have to ask yourself questions
where is this guy going if B4 where is
this guy going if C4 save yourself the
headache
A4 puts an end to all of that there will
be no beep on getting to B5 this guy is
stable this guy
could be kicked eventually but this is
the main thing the Knight on C3 will be
stable
okay
there's a drawback with A4
B4 is now a whole so black takes what
he's been given
he's not playing A6 here
if A6 the bishop can fall back and then
this is a bit too cluttered the space
Advantage here
and the space by white
is I believe seen as an advantage in
this situation so
no A6
in this position for black instead
Knight A6 he's getting to the B4 square
and black is definitely not worried
about this situation here because this
opened B file for black is very
appealing also the B4 Square for a rook
it's very nice as well
so
this Knight's gonna get here
now the Knight goes to F3 on this move
only after first addressing this idea
for black this idea by black to expand
on the queen side
Knight B4
it's not the only way black can go I'd
like to point this out here if
instead of Knight B4 black can Castle
first
and then you know this is also a
possibility the Knight could go to B4 or
C7 totally different ideas in mind if
you're going to C7 you're looking to
continually prep and get that B5 advance
in there but in this game
he simply hops right into B4
castles
A6
and in the game we have Bishop takes
Knight very direct he wants the move
back he's not retreating
and he's meeting the recapture with this
follow-up F5 very aggressive play this
guy is still in the center he has with
F5 opened up the diagonal for the bishop
in the game it's castles
what's happening if Pawn takes Pawn how
can play develop Bishop G5
if the bishop blocks
the bishop can go to H6 very irritating
post for black to deal with
if the queen moves
and we have this capture and all of a
sudden there's this possibility or that
possibility
and finally if F6 in this position the
bishop can fall back
now what would Black's options be
here
well if you capture on e4 check out this
star move
Knight G5
this forces castles here for black still
an even game after Knight G takes on e4
castles Knight G takes E4 and if black
wants to for some reason lose you can
always take the Knight and we're going
to have a mate in two
one other note here
in this position after F6 Bishop H4 of
black castles there's this really neat
move
E5 and this is creating a past D puns
taking advantage of the pinned F6 Pawn
it's still a ball game ahead but I had
to pick a side I'm going with white this
Pawn is very dangerous and I like having
the safer King
in any case that's how play can develop
if black is capturing on F5 on this move
13 but instead he castles
Bishop G5 hits
and the reply here is F6 considered the
best move what other options are there
well if the bishop blocks
not really a good idea to welcome the
exchange of the only
Defender really of the king side
white could continue with Queen D2 and
play a position where the Queen stay on
board seeing how white has the safer
King Pawn Duo is still around we got
these gaps over here on Black's end
so this isn't so attractive and this
also wouldn't be attractive because it
would allow F6
and white could continue with Queen D2
and look out
because we're looking at these moves
next as White Queen H6 Knight G5 with
the idea for mate on H7
so black plays in the best way he shuts
down this diagonal says go somewhere
else
light goes to F4 he's pinpointing the
base point
in comes G takes f
and now Bishop takes D6
Black's reply here we have this Rook
Under Fire
it's a losing move black blunders in
this position he ends up capturing on A4
what is considered best very messy
continuation this is considered best
rookie eight
Bishop takes C5 we have these
captures going on here this check can be
met with Queen D4 with the Knight still
around but after the Knight is captured
this is serious
no time to recapture here Queen B6
would be winning the piece so white has
to defend B6 in this position with one
of these two moves
and it says this is even now don't ask
me
how to assess this one this is way too
messy
okay a lot of a lot of messy positions
with the benoni all right
in the game instead of this we have
Bishop takes A4
Rook takes A4
we're essentially trading what blacks
light Square Bishop has been captured
and
lights dark Square Bishop so what does
this mean
no light Square Bishop around
you're not watching over this sensitive
F5 Square white is not taking on F5 here
there's only one winning continuation
white finds it move 18 watch how quick
this game ends watch how effective a
white knight is when it's on F5 he
circles right in there this is a piece
that has been itching to move he didn't
have
so many great options in the forward
here so he's going to H4 he's getting
out of the way the queen he's getting
out of the way the Rook two pieces have
been helped because of this move and he
will not be denied that F5 Square
all right from here F takes e Knight F5
where do you go you have to be very
careful now as black where you put that
Queen
in the game it's Queen D7 if she goes
forward
pressure on the Knight defending upon
there would be Queen D Queen two G4 and
what is black doing about this
if you withdraw the queen to defend
that's going to be painful
the queen going here or here can both be
met with Knight H6 and you're gonna lose
the queen one way or the other
and if you try to defend with the Rook
yet again Knight H6 lands and there goes
the Rook
so
it is Queen D7
from here Knight takes Pawn
and there's this ID to take the pawn
what do you do about that
in the game King age eight is played why
is King h8 played Black wants to at
least be threatening to take on D5 he
can't do it now
if you take with the queen here 97 hits
there goes the queen
and if you take with the Knight there's
multiple ways to continue from here but
this is the clearest way to see
this one out Queen takes Knight straight
away with check and then you land the
fork and you're up the piece in the end
okay
King h8 was played one other note if
black tries B6 here simply defending C5
white can withdraw The Rook just a step
and right around the corner Rook G3
okay a winning attack
in the game though it is King h a
and after Knight takes C5 black resigns
what are you supposed to do here the
queen is attacked and now with their no
longer a Pawn on C5
this night
is not defended so
Queen is hit the Knight is hit how are
you supposed to defend both
we'll have a look at a couple moves if
Queen B5 in this position
there is 96 with the fork and white is
soon gonna win the exchange
after The Rook moves we capture on G7
and if the queen takes on D5 we're still
going to get into that E6 Square
we just have to first exchange Queens
and then there you go how might this
play out just to make it super clear in
this end game the Knight is no match for
the major piece
so
this one goes no further black nose
White's going to be winning some
material here and simply
threw in the towel just have a look at
this final position
before I sign off here these Knights
look at the ground they cover
that's a lot of squares
and during this 21 move game Guess Who
didn't have to even take a step
the queen she got to watch this whole
game
from home base didn't have to take a
single step but she was definitely
still influential in this game her
presence was still felt these ideas in
some cases to come out to G4 connecting
with this monster Knight on F5
excellent game by Kasparov
completely dominant final position
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below
I hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
foreign